okay
we are about to hit continue on dog
picture
dark pictures house of ashes i can speak
clearly we just fell down a hole
that's the context
jason
and i suspect
that there
is gonna be
a tomb oh flashlight cool
in here and we'll be finding out all
about this curse and more of those big
tooth boys
i'm close man i'm coming
oh
oh my god this is so dark
[ __ ]
i jumped
real hard
like that might have been one of my
worst
oh what that's like have we even been
recording for a minute oh geez
okay
well
i'm just trying to look for my friend
please don't mind me
yeah that's definitely the same thing
i remember the back spikes from the
shadow oh god
can we shoot them
to be fair
nobody has seen these things before
when guns were present right i don't
know how often this eclipse happens
but i don't
like the other guys didn't have guns
okay
yes
i remember seeing this in the trailer as
well i think like one of them does die
pretty close to me but i guess it
depends on the choices i make
where i'm god's greener than we landed
we need to get back topside regroup with
the rest of the squad and signal for
medivac this place ain't no weapon silo
but it sure is [ __ ] crawling with that
i don't think it is my dude
nick
sergeant k
pull yourself together
eyes wide
tell him that i saw something
i saw something
what do you mean shove something
i mean it was a human
in a tunnel
he's not going to believe me there's no
way
i should have never gotten off that hilo
i [ __ ] knew it i knew you weren't
ready for this
i swear to god do not get god involved
in this [ __ ] now i don't want to
hear another [ __ ] word you pull your
[ __ ] together right [ __ ] now before
you get us both killed god their faces
look so good
i don't know people's eyes are quite
that shiny [ __ ]
um
we need to get out of here
we do we need to get out of here right
now game of roll credits we've done it
my gosh
you ever seen anything like this
the hell is this place
it looks like two obvious choices
doesn't it
oh god it's so dark
oh this flashlight trickery is not my
favorite
tell me you don't feel it
what nick can't climb that
i feel like i should go explore that
more thoroughly but i'm not doing it i'm
going to this shiny object
it comforts me
hello
oh this is gonna give me premonition
that is somebody falling
squeeze i want to play it again
hard to say what that means at this
stage
i think squeeze might have been the name
of the
premonition
okay
this thing is heavier than it looks give
me a head
i'm gonna need some more muscle
again
[Music]
oh no
oh
god that's messed up
i do remember that from the from the
conference
he's bleeding out we have to cut him
down right now what is he calling we'll
tap buddy we got you is it bob white
cut the wires
[Music]
you should know you're not supposed to
say that that is pretty basic training
yeah you're not supposed to say that to
someone who's in a state of shock if you
could literally kill them
in my back grab me
we're gonna film oh god
hurry the hell up we got this you keep
lookout
look out for what jesus who the hell
loaded these packs
what the [ __ ] just happened
yeah maurice game got scared real quick
all of a sudden
went from zero to to zero to zero to 100
an hour two oh
my [ __ ]
she's probably still alive oh that's
dude that is so much blood
[Music]
he's bleeding
i don't i don't like his chances
where's it coming from his thighs
he's making noise
[Music]
i have no knowledge if morphine works
that way can you just stab people with
it
no idea
oh man
gosh
i need you with me nick
nick you're killing him
oh i'm accidentally suffocating him
wait wait did i just choose to suffocate
him
oh should i have let go
i didn't need he's gone nick
martin's dead
you just suffocated him to death
did i do that
well
it might be for the best
i thought that i was tapping to let go
oh god
i'm sorry
wow
well
i was wrong i really thought he was
gonna last till the end because he's a
jerk
i suppose not
it's a shame we can't
get the [ __ ] he had in his backpack now
because
the monsters went right for him
yeesh
okay who is this
oh this is the the guy with the kid
anna
is
ain't nobody got signal down here for
some reason does seem strange
it's pretty dope though
do you think that they genuinely didn't
know it was here
maybe they didn't
like it's possible the army did come in
because they knew the americans were
here everyone it's kind of just a
coincidence um i just want to change the
controls
accessibility
i need to single action button that is
get rid of
uh
hold to complete that's what i'm after
that one
so i don't have to do button mashes yeah
beautiful
yes please
okay
so my guess is that those
farmers actually were just on heroin
is in the trade not that they're on on
using the drug actively
and
we've just fell down here
by chance his satellite wasn't wrong in
recognizing something hollow underground
but i don't think it's weapons of mass
destruction
oh god
hey licorice
i mean oh yeah he was dragged yeah you
can't die that way from falling
he was dragged the whole way upstairs
that's gonna be a yikes for me i just
want to see if there's anything over
here
hey
okay
premonition
that seemed like a good outcome
you could climb up away from one of them
yeah i was gonna say i don't really
trust the stability of that staircase
oh
is it the ground moving underneath
this place is we gotta somewhat you did
i didn't say any words
i think we need to get out of here dude
all right
i hope so too buddy
oh no
[Music]
i don't feel good about this at all
hello
oh it's just a labyrinth dude
i really just took a wild guess about
where to turn then i probably should
have explored
a little bit more
hello
and bunny ho
you know
this is prime for jump scare
no
no
i knew it and it still got me
i knew it
they love throwing bodies around these
guys
um
run
[Applause]
i just don't feel like shutting the door
well
the doors actually do seem to be kind of
useful against them but i was gonna say
just don't feel like shutting a door
like one of them you'd just be stuck
there wouldn't you just waste time
they like that too
if i ever want to sneak up on somebody
get really long nails
tick-tock girl nails and just
that seems positive
this seems
yeah
that seems good
okay
i feel good about it
this whole damn place is about to come
down
i'm trying to make him more business
where the hell are the marines
i don't know it happened so fast the
ground just swallowed me up
did you see sergeant k cold check unless
i saw they were together
i tried something's interfering with the
signal
that could be another way out
i don't know
um
reassuring
you know i've got your back rage
stay close you'll be fine
i just have to whistle neal come running
right
sounds about right
carabiners quick draws rope light
[ __ ]
okay
all good
all good is are they both going oh it
made it sound like she was going by
herself for some reason
why would you go down to get up
well that's a steep drop to nowhere
got rope
hey look
there's an airflow
i say we climb
we didn't even like scope out the area
we just went straight for it excuse me
the lighter
it's nothing
just something i picked up back at
are base ready
are you
i admire that bravery
i know rope physics in video games are
really difficult like it is hard to get
ropes to work right
a lot of devs are super impressed by the
rope and the last of his party now how
they actually managed to get that to
work this place doesn't look much like a
weapon silo to me
if there's nothing down here then why
were we attacked there's a war on
people yeah i think she's right
i
i too was on his side initially
and thought that it didn't make sense
but now i think that it's just
they knew the americans were gonna be
there i guess we could classify this as
quality time stop hating on her eric you
and i always did have a different view
somebody's gotta go to hr about this
doesn't matter if you dated you gotta
you gotta chill out she tried to break
up with you all right
you gotta let it be
allow it bro flow it stop it eric you
mean the sense of feeling lost
am i supposed to know what this says
no
wmds only
curse
got it
thanks eric
old
it's ancient
that's uniform
sumerian maybe
what is this place
i guess if these two you're quite the
expert on history i haven't seen
maybe you don't know me as well as you
think anything dangerous which i think
they haven't yet which means it's only a
minute now
um
this would actually just be kind of
amazing
like you'd probably just
be like in bewilderment about what
you've discovered
you'd be ready to call in the
archaeologist you know i'm saying
uh those feature is that just a repeated
asset
it is just a repeated asset i think
the ground texture see one two
three sometimes
you gotta repeat your assets fam
actually literally constantly it's just
not always as noticeable as that because
it was in the same place and not at all
rotated
the floor seems stable
where are we going
oh boy
not that stable
okay
you've got a certain coal under pressure
no no
what do you think this place is
hard to say
these carvings look religious
i think we might be in a temple
it's pazuzu
nice
pazuzu
do you know how much horror movies
you should know the answer to that
it's a sumerian demon
something to do with plagues i think
yeah
pledge and demons a plague demon great
as it were
unbelievable
i was not expecting this at all well
what's that
great that's all we need i mean yeah
this place is not in good shape you all
need to get the [ __ ] out of here as soon
as you possibly can
i think we can move it
looks jammed pretty tight
camera angle is so odd i think this is
the first one they've done where you can
kind of walk around with a gun like this
but i'm not positive
um alrighty
we gotta go further down is gonna be my
guess we already looked at that right
that does seem like a way up where's
that light coming from
we trying to go down
this place is big
and you are going to die if you head
down photo it seems like a bad idea
you didn't hear that
i didn't hear anything
i thought i heard something down there
even in ruins this place is still
something special
i wonder what happened here
that's gunfire
where's it coming from
the the big hole
big hole number two
can you make anything out
that's it's deep
that looks safe to you
it's our only option i would say
no
we're going down
it does not look
safe
but okay
this is a cool setting
uh
oh
unbelievable
we're not the first ones here
damn it
they were here
sorry eric
for real
you put everything into this research
more than you'll ever know
hush you can't blame yourself you blame
himself for what for them falling into
the holes i'll learn from this
i'll go back and work twice as hard wait
what was the problem
oh stronger than that kayla's wasn't
detecting cabins it was detecting
equipment and it was the wrong kind of
equipment you don't believe in me
there's no use in dwelling on it
we need to focus on the task ahead and
find a way out of this place
the hell is that
subsidence
from the aftershocks
nah
it monsters
bigger monsters
this looks like
archeological gear
somebody was studying this ruin
hey we could use those lamps
the light could guide the marines to us
do you think that still works
they don't know about the problems with
the noise
it'll work
just needs gas
we need to find some
okay
[Music]
i don't feel good about it
i hope you're safe
sorry
oh she likes him i thought that maybe
they were just getting it out
she's into him i wish there was a run
button
y'all walk too slow
oh what's this
[ __ ] that's a hell of a lot of fireworks
maybe
whoever was studying the place
knew things were going to go to school
this is king does anyone copy over
you've got to see this i don't know what
i'm looking at
what was that what was i supposed to see
also we could definitely walk over there
fine rachel fine
cataloging these pieces
somewhere
my favorite indie film studio
inspector it's just more dynamite why
would they do that
look at this place
yeah
they must have known
you wouldn't be doing that to a place
like this like the amount of money that
you even get for finding
ancient garbage surely would outweigh
everything but
deathly monster curse
as it were
any gas up here i'm just trying to get
some gas from uh
whatever the [ __ ]
y'all seen any gas oh it's this area
that's one hell of a big yeah well not
quite big enough to get rid of that
mountain
propane
that would be where he sat there i think
that's cool
bobby
i don't really feel the need to inspect
it all
i've got it figured out yeah you know
all right we've done a full circle
okay what about this you're just gonna
look through there again be like you
gotta see this
why do you see how quickly the story's
been blocked off there's something
desperate about it
i wonder who they're trying to keep out
who's gonna tell him
it's monsters
oh god it's a [ __ ] dog
this is king to all call signs are you
receiving over
well then who would be down here you big
dumb ninkan poop
oh no that is english
maybe i'm wrong i'm sorry about that
sorry i called you an income poop of all
things
randolph i trust locals were spooked by
these mountains
i trust this finds you well our journey
to the dig has been delayed we left some
heavy equipment behind in sauron because
pullman could only hire half the men and
mules needed workers refuse to go into
the mountains they are superstitious and
cry that we will be possessed by demons
oh maybe the workers have been possessed
like it's like until
they even refuse to
bonus pay of two dinars each we have
also left the second generator and the
spare radio behind with the agent we
should be with you by the 18th yours
faithfully
no
all right that doesn't imply that
there's fuel get these lights running
asap
i mean i agree
but i don't know why these sons of
[ __ ] left
the propane
he said pogba what's wrong with me
i comfort myself by talking a lot when i
play um r games for let's plays and um
and sometimes it doesn't work out great
i so dark
i cannot see
how can something this vast have
remained hidden good question
okay
[Music]
not feeling very calm
actually feeling pretty bad
about all of this
oh my
oh they fly
oh they can get out whenever they want
yeah we're screwed
you regretting not calling for
additional air support yet
there you go reading my mind again
ooh premonition
interesting okay
what do you think the rest of the squad
are doing i'm sure they're tough
why did you
they'll muscle through do that
maybe climbing out of the cavern back
there would have been the smarter move
uh way i see it if these people were
here before us there must be another way
out
yeah pressing on b doesn't seem to do
anything why did it tell me to do that
okay
um
well
i'm at a loss
that's the radio
um
i have no idea where we found this my
dude i feel like i've been everywhere
is there something
here that i missed
what is this
have no idea what that would be
hmm
it's still not going to let me interact
with you
eric check this out
what would that be yeah that's a good
question
it's a world war ii model
ties in with the time the archaeologists
were here
what the [ __ ] happened here
from a point of defense this place has
some good choke points but
overall it's a weak snap could have been
done under pressure i don't know the
constraints they were working under
i think i've looked at everything right
is there like wild chance that wants me
to look at more of this dynamite
there's a shitload more dynamite here
the hell would they need so much for
for the last result my friend
i think i looked at this stuff today no
okay
cuz of a cut
let me pick that back up
scholars regard the curse of akada's
fiction an inter instructional story
that trained the sumerians to enjoy a
famine fate in the whims of the gods
however the discovery of this great
temple hints at a new truth behind it in
the original tale the god and and lil
turns against king naram sinav
at first the king is poised and
pentenant
penitent
praying for answers but after seven
years the gods have given none so naram
sin
decides to bring them to a county raises
an army and marches to the city of
nepada sac and lost temple this blossomy
is so great that enlil the roaring storm
enlists the gods against naram sims
sending the gootians to raise our card
to the ground
destroy its farms and curse the people
with famine
yeah
sort of appears that way if i'm being
honest
oh sick tape
tight i love tape
no i took it great cool
oh sweet tape
i'll take that thank you
i don't know what for
pretty sure i already looked at this one
but just possibly been faced with that
required all this make sure we've got
them all done
okay
take a look at this tent then
oh that looks like gas
eric come give me a hand with these cans
oh time we had a little luck
how's the lake holding these camera
angles are so
nerve-wracking
oh you mean the prosthesis i lost my leg
back on the highway
don't
i still feel guilty
i didn't make it easy on you rage
i know that what
you weren't to blame for that correct
mom let's get to work
it's i'm jumping so much
but it's not even that bad oh my god
okay
shine a light on the tank
hands are back all the handsy hands is
back
i wonder what they wait for shh i would
like to understand the mechanics of
these monsters please
what's wrong
fuel tubes worn loose the damn valve is
leaking i got tape can it be fixed
we have to secure the tube before
starting the generator tape i have it
yeah i have tape do you want tape i got
some
you're welcome
you got it
yeah dude
extremely resourceful don't worry about
it stop looking at me like that
you're making me uncomfortable once you
said back at the base
you were wrong
it doesn't sound like me
you said nothing had changed between us
life changed
all that time spent away from each other
you have to stop dude
i kind of don't buy that he's in a
position of power you feel the same way
even a little
i meant what i said
it was over between us the minute that
truck hit my car wow damn nothing has
changed that's
that's what happened
you have to stop dude you're you're at
work right now you gotta chill out you
can't keep pulling this out on it
and i like you more than i like her hold
the fuel pipe
you have these conversations in your own
time not when you're fixing generators
in like
finger hell
hey give me a hand with this panel
fuses
look at the state of these
they're shot unsurprising
then we could do this with a little less
attitude i'm trying to work
why do we leave shut up eric
you made it so hard for me to stay
we should have stuck together
i don't think either of us expected to
be out of each other's lives for so long
past year or so my head's been buried
and chaos and
i was blind to anything else
your work is bigger than the both of us
like i don't think either of us could
have foreseen the impact it would have
yeah but i still don't want to be with
you to be clear
rage
can we fix this [ __ ] generator say
what's on i'm trying to fix this
generator
that's what he needs to say that's
what's done i missed you rach
like you wouldn't believe
back then
i don't know things seem confused but
now
it just seems simpler
it's the past eric
we have to put it behind us and look oh
my god i thought that was a monster hand
it's okay
i'm happy to look to that future
i'm happy to look to getting this
generator working that should do the
trick
let's fire up
okay
what could go wrong
the radio still working is the
implication
i want to go scope out that big tent
though there was something in there that
i didn't grab we have power
there was a way in for these people
there's a way out for us let's take a
look around
oh my
okay well at least
they both believe
what's happening here now right
i really feel like that would work
monsters are always just
invulnerable to guns
just so often
we gotta go through it the other way
oh god okay
through we're in a rush
didn't seem that unsafe
that mocap was really good
the animation
okay
[Applause]
oh my god they're just like giant
bats
yeah i had a theory that they were like
people who had been
turned to whoever the excavators were
but
let's go
i don't know now man maybe it is the
curse maybe
i don't know
i did want to check out this nice tent
though
the journal
of randolph hodgson
september the 24th
1945
when lady bradshaw summons you ah indeed
sir terry
mary's eye sumerian relic recovered from
a dick site in the hashemite kingdom of
iraq
after dinner she showed us another find
from the same site
a gold uniform that's the one we saw on
the wall
she called it the final puzzle piece in
her life's work
a map that pinpoints the tomb of
alexander immigrant
if she's right
the tomb lies somewhere on the border of
iraq
lady bradshaw wants us to lead her
expedition
i realize now that our honeymoon will
take place in a dusty dig site in the
sagros mountains
that's where we are my dude
that was cool
this place is starting to make me feel a
little uneasy
no there's something else here
a picture
oh it's a picture 1945.
what happened to these guys the hudson
expedition
cherry
apparently that accent never existed
very fun to do but apparently
was always just somebody putting on a
voice it was never a real thing
so they couldn't open that
um
i feel like i probably went to that room
from earlier too soon
and that maybe i need to go back there
oh he's over by the radio let's check
that out
what's on the radio
still nothing
eric take a look at this
okay still nothing but now it's light
find out shall we strange that they
needed that
the tape is all tangled up
generator to fix that unless it is
connected it's fine i can fix that
she's crafty
someone just stop
when did you stop wearing yours
it doesn't
always close to my heart
i moved on
stopped wearing it the day i left
i've moved on eric
he he's lost me i really was on his side
i want you back rachel
i know dude but like right now you're
like the leader of this troop and
everybody's [ __ ] missing
there is someone else
someone else now
i knew it
the bones of this temple are drenched in
blood
we have set foot on an uncharted shore
and wow something ancient and with you
does this mean he's saying this this
eloquently while people are screaming
and dying around him
i fear being taken
but i must do what i must
we will seal this place for eternity
for all mankind
that
is why
the dynamite is there
oh no
hello
good guy bad guy
you know i feel like maybe you just need
to chill out for like a second
like maybe now is not
the time
to be trying to kill
your fellow man
for me
the hell is going on
i don't know man
it was not supposed to play out like
this
king this is mailman two one axel how
copy over
how copy
not that i know what mailman 21 actual
means is that like his
code name
what why did you what wasn't you at that
giant locked door
how did you get here something simple
this goddamn place
you're not serious that looks decades
old that's what we have
oh we don't have our ropes can you see
him
oh
yeah he's coming
he's gonna get killed
i think he'll take care of himself
you really can't put your controller
down in this game it seems like a
cutscene but it's not
the whole video game
seems like a cutscene but it not
oh god
that's
pretty scary
rachel
oh my god
i got you rich i've got you this shitty
old rope
maybe
it worked
[Music]
i don't feel great about this
oh
look at how frayed it is oh no
rachel grab on i'm actually nervous i
can't see this is like one of the
lightest places in this whole stupid
[ __ ] cave dude
come on
[ __ ]
damn it you hold still
i don't feel good about it and i'm
talking about it
i'm sorry rachel
i'm so sorry
no
no
no
he might die
[Music]
i don't want to cut her off dude
okay i guess no
oh he's coming [ __ ]
no okay okay it's nick i thought that it
was maybe the bad guy
why is she being so quiet
not
great oh thank god we were dead silent
that whole time he didn't hear a thing
how could he have possibly heard
nothing happened nothing happened at all
don't worry about it everything's fine
[Laughter]
what nightmare have these luckless souls
a good question
poor rachel has been lost to the
darkness
it didn't go out to so much as she did
jason and nick
brothers in arms but are they really as
close as they appear
or will it be a case of each man for
himself
let's not forget that they've already oh
yeah so rachel's probably still alive or
they would have shown her dying
she's by herself now
merwin is dead
he seems level-headed
an almost reluctant soldier
perhaps
an unwelcome fate
now i don't know that it was ever
welcome trapped beneath the earth
swallowed
by the boy
such a good performance yeah the [ __ ]
facial capture just looks so good unless
you can find the means
i will try i'm curious if i ever could
have saved mowing
i
think i could have i checked him out by
accident maybe myself with the affairs
of others but
it does keep things interesting
i can offer you some words of advice
as long as you are willing to keep this
strictly between us um youtube stop
listening just stop listening right now
if you guys just stopped paying
attention
and everybody just stopped listening
says just me and him i promise
a prudent choice all things considered
long ago i met a blind poet who
impressed upon me these wise words
long as the way and hard
out of hell
leads up to light
that's all
long is the way in hard that out of hell
leaves up to light
okay
i don't know what he meant by that
[Music]
where's rachel
where is she
she fell
and may be fine but she's not saying
anything which is very strange
happened to rachel
we were amazed by the enemy
he opened fire on us
yeah
she fell she did yeah
i hold on
hello as long as i could
rachel
we gotta move
colonel we're sitting ducks
we need to fall back now
over there that was a weird like change
of his face there that was strange
look at that
sold
you can still be here
right now colonel oh yeah he doesn't
know about him
they're not following
this is mailman two one actual to all
call signs how copy over
joey report in over
joey's dead
the [ __ ] you talking about the iraqi
store right through them oh yeah joey is
dead
there's four left
if rachel's alive which i think she is
are you guys going to tell him about
about that lock this place down form a
defensive perimeter and buy ourselves
damn
the monsters you're going to let him
know
lieutenant
what did you mean when you said the iraq
is the least of our worries
you believe in god
absolutely not
we'll start believing we are under
attack by
i don't know what
you wouldn't believe me even if i tried
hell
i don't believe in knives there
monsters
monsters
come on you're jumping at [ __ ] with all
due respect lieutenant you haven't seen
how long their fingers are dude you
wouldn't understand
whatever you think you've seen it's
[ __ ]
these statues
nick
take a mental picture and snap the [ __ ]
out of it what is this place
it's not the silos that's for sure this
mission's a bust
i can fix this
the satellite
will go over the data to improve the
algorithm
they're clearly teething problems
um
i'd be pretty pissed about that i think
i'll [ __ ] your satellite good men have
died
clarisse is gone your wife is dead eric
you let us on a suicide that's okay i
didn't want to go that hard okay i'm
still in command here you'd better
remember your rank lieutenant
and i don't feel like you should be in
commander excuse me
she's very obsessed with
who got us into this mess
you better get us out
do you want to repeat that
that's what i thought
there goes the gas huh
maybe they would chill because there's
light do they not like being in light
staying guard the entrance i feel like
that's entirely possible
gotta go back repair it huh
all right i'm gonna call this part right
here
thank you all for joining me we'll have
part three up in probably in a couple of
days i'll probably wait a little bit
between these two but um
i'm invested
wonder if rachel's alive hope eric gets
over it